I'd like to talk about a face detection
all right so this is the idea or if
you've got a picture with one face in it
or many faces in it how do we find those
faces and the standard approaches I will
just use deep learning now you can use
deep learning to find faces but actually
the approach for everyone uses isn't
deep learning and it was developed in
the early 2000s
so back before deep learning what did
everything you kind of had to come up
with these algorithms yourself right
machine learning was still a thing
so people still use machine learning but
they used in with handcrafted features
and and they and small neural networks
and other kinds of classifiers that they
tried to use to do these things now the
face detection was you know ongoing
research at this time in 2002 Paul viola
Michael Jones came up with this paper
here called rapid object detection using
a boosted cascade of simple features and
this is a very very good paper it's been
cited some 17,000 times and despite the
fact that deep learning has kind of
taken over everything in face detection
this still performs absolutely fine
right it's incredibly quick and if
you've got any kind of camera that does
some kind of face detection it's going
to be using something very similar to
this right so what does it do let's talk
about that the problem is right there's
a few problems with face detection one
is that we don't know how big the face
is going to be it so it could be very
big could be very small and another is
you know maybe you've got a very
high-resolution image we want to be
doing this lots and lots of times a
second so what are we going to do to
look over every every tiny bit of image
lots and lots of times complicated
machine learning but it says you know is
this a faces it's not a face if there's
a trade-off between speed and accuracy
and false-positives and false-negatives
is a total mess it's very difficult to
find faces quickly right this is also
considering it you know we have
different ethnic groups young old people
people who've got glasses on things like
this so all of this adds up to quite a
difficult problem and yet it's not a
problem we worry about anymore because
we can do it and we can do it because of
these guys they came up with a
classifier that uses very very simple
features one bit of an image subtracted
from another bit of an image and on its
own and that's not very good but if you
have thousands and thousands of those
all giving you a clue that maybe this is
a face you could start to come up with
proper decision is this looking for
facial features then is it as simple as
looking for a nose in an eye and etc so
no not really
right so deep learning kind of does that
right it takes it takes edges and other
features and it combines them together
into objects you know in a hierarchy and
then maybe it finds faces what this is
doing is making very quick decisions
about what it is to be a face so in for
example if we're just looking at a
grayscale image right my eye is arguably
slightly darker than my forehead might
in terms of shadowing and the pupils
darker and things like this so if you
just do this bit of image - this bit of
image my eye is going to produce a
different response - from this
blackboard right most of the time now if
you do that on its own that's not a very
good classifier right
it'll get quite a lot of the faces but
it'll also find a load of other stuff as
well where something happens to be
darker than something else that happens
all the time so the question is can we
produce a lot of these things all at
once and make a decision that way they
proposed these very very simple
rectangular features which are just one
part of an image subtracted from another
part of an image so there are a few
types of these features one of them is a
two rectangle features so we have a
block of image where we subtract one
side from the other side there
approaches and machine learning based
approach normally what you would do in
machine learning is you would extracts
it you can't put the whole image in
maybe there's five hundred faces in this
image so we put in something we've
calculated from the image some features
and then we use all machine learning to
try and classify bits of the image or
the whole image or something like this
their contribution was a very quick way
to calculate these features and use them
to make a face classification to say
there is a face in this block of image
although isn't right and be the features
they use a super simple right so they're
just rectangular features like this so
we've got two rectangles next to each
other which you know are some amount of
pixels so maybe it's a it's nine pixels
here and nine pixels here or just one
pixel and one pixel or hundred pixels
and a hundred pixels it's not really
important and we do one subtract the
other right so essentially we're looking
for bits of an image where one bit is
darker or brighter than another bit this
is a two rectangle feature
it can also be oriented the other way so
you know like this we also have three
rectangle features which are like this
where you're doing sort of maybe the
middle subtract the outside or vice
versa and we have four rectangle feature
which are going to be kind of finding
diagonal sort of corner things so
something like this even if your image
is small right you're going to have a
lot of different possible features even
of these four types so this four
rectangle feature could just be one
pixel each or each of these could be
half the image it can scale you know or
move and move around what determines
that so they do all of them right
or at least they look at all of them
originally and they learn which ones are
the most useful for finding a face this
over a whole image of a face isn't
hugely representative of what a face
looks like right no one's face the
corners are darker than the other two
corners that doesn't make sense right
but maybe over there I maybe that makes
more sense I don't know that's not the
kind of the idea so they have a training
process at which was down which of these
features are useful the other problem
we've got is that on an image
calculating large groups of pixels and
summing them up is quite a slow process
so they come a really nifty idea called
an integral image which makes this way
way faster so let's imagine we have an
image right and so think consider while
we're talking about this that we want to
kind of calculate these bits of image
but minus some other bit of image right
so let's imagine we have an image which
is nice and small it's too small for me
to write on but let's not worry about it
right and that's drawing some pixel
values
fast forward look at the state of that
that's that's a total total shambles
this is a bubble out pin right I'm gonna
say right okay so all right let's
imagine this is our input image we're
trying to find a face in it now I can't
see one but obviously this could be a
quite a lot bigger and we want to
calculate let's say one of our two
rectangle features so maybe we want to
do these four pixels up in the top minus
the four pixels below it now that's only
a few additions 7 plus 7 plus 1 plus 2
minus 8 plus 3 plus 1 plus 2 but if
you're doing this over large sections of
image and thousands and thousands of
times to try and find faces that's not
going to work so what the other than
jonna's came up with was this integral
image where we pre compute some of this
arithmetic for us store it in an
intermediate form and then we can
calculate rectangles minus of of
rectangles really easily so we do one
pass over the image and every new pixel
is the sum of all the pixels
above and to the left and it including
it right so this will be something like
this so 1 + 1 + 7 is 8 so this pixel is
the sum of these two pixels and this
pixel is going to be always 3 so that's
going to be 12 14 23 and now we fast
forward while I do a bit of math in my
head 8 17 maybe I did somebody's earlier
24 on a computer this is much much
faster the sum of all the pixels is 113
for example the sum of this 4x4 block is
68 now the reason this is useful bear
with me here but if we want to work out
what let's say the sum of this region is
what we do is we take this one 113 we
subtract this one minus 64 alright and
this one minus 71 and that's taken off
all of that and all of that and then we
have to add this bit in because we've
been taken off twice so in plus 40 all
right so that's for reads now finally
off this is a 4 by 4 block so I've
achieved nothing but if this was a huge
huge image I've saved a huge amount of
time and the answer to this is 18 which
is 6 plus 6 plus 5 plus 1 so the
assumption is that I'm not just going to
be looking at these pictures one time to
do this right there's lots of places a
face could be I've got to look at lots
of combinations of pixels and different
regions so I'm going to be doing huge
amounts of pixel addition and
subtraction so let's calculate this
integral image once and then use that as
a base to do really quick adding and
subtracting of regions right and so I
think for example a for rectangle region
is going to take something like nine
Reed's or something like that and a
little bit addition it's very simple all
right so now how do we turn this into a
working face detector let's imagine we
have a picture of a face which is going
to be one of my good drawings again now
in this particular algorithm they look
24 by 24 pixel regions but they can also
scale up and down a little bit so let's
imagine there's a face here which has
you know eyes their nose and a mouth
right and some hair okay good now as I
mentioned earlier there are probably
some features that don't make a lot of
sense on this so subtracting for example
if I take my red pen subtracting this
half of image from this half it's not
going to represent most faces it may be
when there's a lot of lighting on one
side but it's not very good at
distinguishing images that have face
and images that don't have faces in so
what they do is they calculate all of
the features right for a 24 by 24 image
they calculate all 180,000 possible
combinations of 2 3 & 4 rectangle
features and they work out which one for
a given data set of faces and not faces
which one best separates the positives
from the negatives right so let's say
you have 10,000 pictures of faces 10,000
pictures of background which one feature
best says this is a face this is not a
face right bearing in mind nothing is
going to get it completely right with
just one feature so the first one it
looks it turns out is something like
this it's a two rectangle region but
works have a difference between the area
of the eyes and the air for cheeks so
it's saying but on a normal face your
cheeks are generally brighter or darker
than your eyes so what they do is they
they say okay well let's start a
classifier with just that feature right
and see how good it is this is our first
feature feature number one and we have a
pretty relaxed fresh hold so if there's
anything plausible in this region we'll
let it through right which is going to
let through all of the faces and a bunch
of other stuff as well that we don't
want right so this is yes that's okay
right that's okay if it's a no then we
immediately fail that region of image
right so we've done one test which is as
we know about for additions so we've
said for this region of image if this
passes will let it through to the next
stage
right and we'll say okay it definitely
could be a face it's not not a face does
that make sense
yeah okay so let's do look at the next
feature the next feature is this one so
it's a three region feature and it
measures the difference between the nose
and the bridge and the eyes right which
may or may not be darker or lighter all
right so there's a difference there so
this is feature number two so I'm going
to draw that in here number two and if
that passes we go to the next feature so
this is a sort of binary they call it a
degenerate decision tree right well
because the decision tree is a binary
tree this is not really because you
immediately stop here you don't go any
further the argument is that every time
we calculate one of these features it
takes a little bit of time the quicker
we can say no definite not a face in
there the better and the only time we
ever need to look at all the feet
or all of the good ones is when we think
okay - actually could be a face heal so
we have less and less general more and
more specific features going forward
right up to about the number I think
it's about six thousand they end up
using all right so we we say just the
first one pass yes just a second one
pass yes and we keep going until we get
a fail and if we get all the way to the
end and nothing fails that's a face
right and the beauty of this is that for
the vast majority of the image if
there's no competition at all we just
take one look at it first feature fails
that's another face they designed a
really good way of adding and
subtracting different regions of the
image and then they trained a classifier
like this to find the best features and
the best order to apply those features
which was a nice compromise between
always detecting the faces that are
there and false positives and speed
right and at the time this was running
on I think to give you some idea of what
the computational technology was like in
2002 this was presented on a 700
megahertz Pentium 3 and ran at 15 frames
a second which was totally unheard of
back then it was wait face detection was
the kind of offline you know it was okay
at that time so this is a really really
cool algorithm and it's so effective
that you still see it used in you know
in your camera phone and in this camera
and so on when you just get a little
bounding box around the face and this is
still really useful because you might be
doing deep learning on something like
face recognition my face ID something
like this but part of that process is
firstly working out where the face is
and why reinvent the wheel when this
technique works really really well you
get into the data center necessarily and
take all the chips out that you've put
in there so you probably will make the
chips look like they're meant to be
there like they're something else or
hide them so the way a modern printed
circuit board is constructed it's a
printed circuit board that's got several
layers of five